moments like this the best word you can
use to describe it is shock more
importantly a heart sweep with all those
who lost and all those families who lost
loved ones and all those fans and and
music lovers that are out there fighting
for the lives and hospitals right now
country duo Big and Rich share their
condolences following the mass shooting
at the route 91 Harvest Festival in Las
Vegas on Sunday the band performed at
6:30 p.m. mere hours before the gunman
opened fire first heard the shooting had
occurred
we were down the street we had pulled
our bus out I was on the bus getting
ready to step back off of it when I look
down I saw three SWAT guys with guns
pointed in my direction so my hand
something I say guys it's me we just
played like I can't come
and it was just hysteria down blocks
away they thought there was multiple
shooters throughout the city but you
know when fear starts spreading like
that mysterious start spreading like
that then you don't know I own a bar in
Las Vegas it's a khutba little live
country music bar and so we had gone
there to play some music after our show
for the fans we thought at any minute
something could come blasting through
the door you know if it was to that
level then our hearts and prayers are
with you and may we all heal as quickly
as possible find comfort someway in the
midst of this this tragedy and know that
that fear will not overtake us
you